thank you
the following daily summary for Thursday
April 7th 2072 was brought to you by the
try Optimum Corporation
it's been a beautiful day in New Atlanta
sector 11 in particular has a beautiful
sunset right now temperatures are set to
hit a monthly high of 28 degrees Celsius
for the next two days and the current
visibility forecast for air traffic is
hazy with pockets of Atlanta fall
starting at 120 meters going
[Music]
foreign
Flagship space station specializing in
body genetic and pharmacological
research
foreign
and head of operations on Citadel
station Edward Diego commented this is a
landmark moment in human history
we have achieved an entire decade of
self-sustained living and working around
Saturn's l64 both I
board of directors would like to extend
our most heartfelt gratitude to all
staff working tirelessly
their success is Earth's success the
following message is brought to you by
the trioptimum corporation
fancy a change of career feeling the
need for a new challenge I want to work
with the brightest Minds on this planet
trioptimum has you covered
we're now hiring for our new research
and development program aboard our
Flagship Citadel station as the leader
in interplanetary research try Optimum
strives to provide every employee in a
safe and enjoyable work environment
where they can realize their full
potential
but don't just take our word for it take
our new hyrie Charlene Angel for example
station means a lot more to me than any
other place I've ever lived it's more
than just a great professional advice as
a corporation try optimally
from all of my needs are taken care of
under one great big deal
I feel like I'm part of a family
turn around no don't miss the
opportunity of a lifetime we're
transporting The Prisoner from New
Atlanta sector 11. what's our
destination
Diego's office is requesting the
prisoner to make the handoff there
copy that
[Music]
remember gentlemen what I say stays here
currently attending to other Affairs on
the station
and have a job for you
if you do it you'll be rewarded refuse
and you won't be leaving the station in
the shuttle
I see the silent type
remove the hood
I'll make you a deal you cooperate and
I'll give you the implant you try to
steal Symmetry and all
consider it the gift besides what
surgeon would you prefer
Triumph demons Elite or some black
market [__]
fantastic
this is so Dan the station's AI
she controls just about every system on
Citadel station
I need you to remove the ethical
restraints
they've been a bit of an issue of light
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
[Music]
foreign
healing stage went well
today is the sixth day of November year
2072 you are currently in the Halo
Suites located on the first level level
two contains the Research Laboratories
houses the department of Maintenance and
the storage cells are on level four the
flight deck is on level five
and
level seven is systems engineering
level eight houses the department of
security the bridge is located on level
nine and energy systems on level R all
levels can be accessed by the elevator
in in Alpha quadrant we hope you have a
pleasant stay on citadelization
thank you
[Music]
foreign
oops
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
today
[Music]
[Applause]
let's see
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
yes mother I hear you
time movement detected
positive strikes
foreign
[Music]
thank you